for the most unique and ancient site in
all of sri lanka you'll need to look up
way way up
[Music]
located 660 feet on top of a rock
plateau in the mathal district of sri
lanka lay the ruins of a 5th century
fortress of king kasyap
the shape and size of the rock jutting
out from the jungle below was created by
hardened lava from an extinct volcano
which dates back to prehistoric times
the rock formation has come to be known
by the name segedia or lion rock after
the large stone lion that once marked
the entrance to the staircase
visitors climbing to the top should
prepare for the 1200 steps it will take
to scale cigaria
to distract from the steep climb
visitors can study the 1500 year old
frescoes painted all along the rocks
at the top are the abandoned remains of
the king's fortress along with an
incredible view of what are believed to
be some of the oldest landscape gardens
in the world
it's a long climb but once at the top
you'll be experiencing what is referred
to by locals as the eighth wonder of the
world
[Music]
you